foreign
as more of China goes into lockdown
frustration continues to build weekend
demonstrations in Shanghai and other
cities reached a scale rarely seen on
the mainland we want covid-19 measures
based on science
I think we should go back to normal we
should go back to normal life
the protest was sparked by the deaths of
at least 10 people in
suggest covid-19 restrictions may have
hampered rescue efforts authorities deny
that's the case
in Hong Kong on Monday an expression of
sympathy and a sign of discontent
in this activism-minded city there's a
feeling of affinity
this is something that has connected us
before during the 2019 protests many
people on the mainland saw us as
aggressors and there's people who solved
problems through violence today I think
they see that it's normal for people to
come out and say what they want and do
what they want well the protests on
Mainland have brought back a lot of
memories of the demonstrations that took
place here in Hong Kong in 2019 and
that's why it's struck a chord for many
people here it's hard to say how many
people have turned out for this vigil
but a lot of people have been leaving
behind candle lights as a mark of
respect for those who died in the room
chair and also leaving many messages of
support for protesters as well
the protests are putting unprecedented
pressure on China's zero covert policy
they're among the toughest in the world
with tens of millions of people
currently under some form of lockdown
there has been some softening of the
rules in certain areas but overall the
government is vowing to stick to its
approach
can you China has been following the
dynamic zero covered policy and has been
making adjustments based on the reality
on the ground we believe that with the
leadership of the Communist Party of
China and the cooperation of the Chinese
people our fight against covid-19 will
be successful
however a witness to corporate may be
waning the Crackdown has been Swift and
decisive
after three years of zero covert this
could be the policy's biggest test yet
Patrick Falk Al Jazeera Hong Kong